ومن ابهى الى جازان اجواء رمضانيه مختلفه
تتميز بها السعوديه في رمضان بتقاليدها
وعاداتها التي لا تتغير او تندثر مع مرور
الوقت زميلنا العزيز الغالي محمد طميحي
ضيفنا اليوم في مساء العربيه في فقره
افطار مع ليقدم لنا لمحه عن الافطار
السعودي الاصيل تحديدا من منطقه جنوب
السعوديه شوف سهامه متعود اطلع معاكم في
الموجز لاهم الانباء صح او نقرا نشر سوا
بس ماني متعود انه مطبخ سوا اليوم طبعا
حلو كيف التجربه سائل العربيه لصباح
العربيه
انت موجود احنا سعداء
موجود خلينا يلا دغري خلينا نعرفكم تعريف
سريع بالصحون اللي موجوده عندنا طبعا هذا
الحنيد احنا نسميه في المنطقه الجنوبيه
بالدال الجوزاء بالتحديد نسميه حنيد زي ما
اعرف انا هو طبعا مشهور انه حنيذ بالذال
وطبعا يختلف بشكل كبير عن المندي لانه
يتعامل بشكل مباشر مع الحراره
وياخذ لون دائما يكون اسمر بهاراته وتختلف
اللحمه شوي جافه تختلف عن المندي ممكن
تكون اللحمه شويه طريه
جدا على الاطار بالنسبه للي جوعان على
الافطار بس في العاده ناخذهم في العشاء
وفي الولائم والمنطقه الثانيه هذه طبعا
اللي هو هذا اللي هو يسمونه المغش واللي
نحط في التنور ويطبخ مع اللحم مع الخضار
احيانا مع البطاطس مع اشياء زي كذا مثلا
لو تشوف مثلا
طبعا الكميه طبعا تختلف اكيد الناتج بيكون
مختلف لكن في النهايه وهو راح يستخدم في
التنور بهارات خاصه
وينحط مع خضار على حسب الرغبه طبعا وفلفل
وملح ايضا ودائما الخضروات هي اللي تعطيه
قيمه مهمه جدا هو اكل صحي بشكل كبير
تسلم
فهذا هو اللي راح يكون
الخلاصه طبعا في ناس ياكلونه مثلا مع
العيش عيش الذره وفي ناس ياكلونه مع
الدقيق او لبن لا هذا شيء مختلف راح نوصل
له بس خلونا نخلص من المرسى بما انه صيام
سهله
بما انه تكلمنا عن المرسى تفضلوا لو
سمحتوا تفضلوا خلنا نبدا نحضر مع بعض
المرسى طبعا هذا ما هو خبز صراحه معتاد بس
هذا اللي قدرت اطبخ اليوم
للعائله انا ماني متعود اسوي دقيق بس راح
تبدا بالتفتيت
خماش على انك تقشر الموز
طيب اوكي بس هيك بسيطه جدا يعني
[موسيقى]
طبعا اكيد بالتاكيد
بس اللي لازم يكون في عمليه
نخلص وقت البرنامج زي ما يقول المخرج
يعني اللي يطلع منك خلص اثنين طيب احنا شو
عم نحضر محمد حتى الناس تعرف هذه طبعا
بالنسبه للصائمين نحتاجوا بشكل كبير
سكريات والمرسى اللي تنحط مع السكر ومع
العسل ومع الموز بس هاي بتتاكل كطبق حلو
حلو طبعا بالتاكيد حلو حلو مغذي بشكل كبير
ما راح نخلص
طيب وهذا هو الناتج طبعا هو تتكون من بشكل
معروف طبعا في اشياء قريبه من يسمونه مثلا
المعصوب واشياء اخرى لكن في النهايه
الخبز الدقيق يستخدم للتنور يستخدم مع
الموز ويستخدم مع العسل والسكر واطلع
بالطريقه النتيجه هذه طبعا لو تشوفون
اللون الغامق لانه في مثلا فتره طويله
قضاها الموز في الهواء في تصير لونه اغمق
اوكي وجبه مغربيه
شوف خلونا من هذا كله انا انسان جدا
متواضع في اكلي انت فعلا يعني
احب الصحن هذا اللي هو بالنسبه اللي
يسمونه لبن
[موسيقى]
هو لبن بالنسبه لي انا لانه ماني عارف
احضر القطيب اللي نسميها قطيبه بشكل صحيح
فاستخدم الزبادي بستخدم عليه بهارات معينه
اوكي طبعا هذا كله من ايام العزوبيه بعد
ما زوجت الامور اختلفت بس انا زوجتي لها
طريقه طبخ مختلفه تماما عن طريق الطبخي
بالنسبه للبهارات اللي موجوده هنا
البهارات ايضا تختلف مثلا عندك الان
الفلفل الكمون ثوم الفلفل الحار وكلها
توضع وتخلط بطريقه معينه من اجل انها بعد
اذنك ممكن اخذه الملعقه
محترف محمد على فكره والله
حبيت اشكر طبعا
هذه
ايضا
كادا معين مع دقيق بشكل حلو جدا واللي ما
يحب عنده مشكله مع الحر اتمنى انه ما يجرب
طويله
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لنا طبعا يس اكيد بالنسبه لنا
قولوا بسم الله
الف صحه يا محمد اكيد احنا جاهزين بعد
الحلقه يعني دعينا كل كل الشباب والبنات
والكواليس
وليمه معك يا محمد
وسمعنا انه في كمان حلو برضو
طب انا عندي سؤال محمد في مناطق الجنوب
السعودي يعني هل الاكلات كل يوم بالافطار
حار أهم لازم تكون موجوده
اكون مسؤول عن ثقافه انا اتكلم عن عاداتي
اليوميه انا شخصيا وجبه الافطار مهم جدا
عندي اللي هو القطيبه اللي هو عمليه جبال
المتوفر هو زبادي
وطبعا اكيد مع الخبز طبعا هذا الخبز يعتبر
فقير جدا مقارنه بالخبز
في التنور
وبالتاكيد طبعا المغش لانه يتميز
بانه مطبوخ بنفس زيوت نفس الزيوت اللي
ماخوذه من نفس
يعني مغذي بشكل كبير مع اشياء اخرى وايضا
لانه يطبخ طبعا هو اخذ اسمه من الاناء
اللي يطبخ فيه سموه مغش في اماكن اخرى
ممكن يسمى بورما في اماكن اخرى ممكن يسمى
في جره ولكن هذا الطبخه عالميا معروفه على
حسب الاناء اللي تطبخ اللي بذكرك الايام
لما كان محمد طميحي في جازان يعني الطبق
اللي بعمل لك نوستالجيا لمنطقه
هي مجرد ما تتذكر المرسى تتذكر كل
الذكريات الطيبه لان المرسى دائما مرتبطه
بالافراح بالمناسبات السعيده وعلى عكس
الناس ممكن يحلوا بعد الاكل احنا بدايه
الاكل هو بالمرسى وهذه هي العادات اللي
اللي تعودنا عليها طبعا من افضل الاشياء
انه المرسى تصنع مباشره لما تخرج من
التنور الدقيق خبز الدقيق نفسها لما يخرج
من التنور يتم فرمه بشكل مباشر ووضع الموز
عليه بشكل مباشر فبالتالي يكون فريش
وبالتالي يكون طعمته جيده ما بين الموز
البارد ما بين الحسن كذا
معانا شكرا جزيلا
واكيد دقائق لا تكفينا لنتعرف على طقوس
سعادات منطقه الجنوب في السعوديه وجاهزين
للاكل
في امان الله الى اللقاء